[Music]
which
came first the chicken
or the egg aristotle postulated that
both chicken
and egg were essential properties of the
universe
extending infinitely back in time
plutarch
argued that the question pointed to the
bigger question of whether the universe
had a beginning
and here we find ourselves in need of
help from the world's greatest thinkers
to settle this issue once and for all
you might imagine that evolution
explains life
but it doesn't and scientists remain
perplexed
as to how and where life emerged are we
simply the result of a fluke event one
chemical reaction billions of years ago
are we right to turn to the biologists
to tell us
or does the issue in fact lie deeper
so to help us unpack this awesome uh
debate basically in conversation we have
three wonderful panelists
we have sarah walker who is a
theoretical physicist turned
astrobiologist she's currently the
deputy director of the center
for fundamental concepts in science
where she is most interested in whether
or not
there are laws of life that could
universally describe life here on earth
and
also other planets we also are joined by
nick lane
who is a professor of evolutionary
biochemistry at university college
london
his research focuses on the way that
energy flows has shaped evolution over
four billion years
he is the author of four acclaimed books
on evolutionary biochemistry
which have sold more than five hundred
thousand copies worldwide
and last but by no means least at all we
we are joined by uh daniel dannett
uh who is the professor of philosophy at
tufts university
his research centers on philosophy of
mind and philosophy of science
particularly as those fields relate to
evolutionary biology
and cognitive science he's a prolific
author
and has written well over a dozen books
including the bestsellers
consciousness explained and breaking the
spell
religion as a natural phenomenon
so can we
see how we might put together a credible
origin
uh sorry a credible theory on the origin
of life
and does it answer the question about
the chicken and the egg
importantly let's let's start with nick
why not nick you're up okay
yes all right um so i i
i don't really understand the question
of the chicken in the egg i have to say
um i think biology itself answered that
long ago
uh in safaris eggs go right back to
single-celled
organisms not the chicken's egg but
the idea of an egg of two sexes and so
on and that really encapsulates the idea
of evolutionary change over time
um and and and how things can evolve
uh and i would you you you kind of
slightly dismissed biology
as a question at the origin of life uh
in your introduction
strangely it seems to me the biologists
have been the group who have had
less to say about the origin of life i
would say there's a field it's been
dominated by chemists over the last 50
or 60 years
it's a question that goes right across
science of course or
pretty much every discipline you can
think of plays a major role in trying to
understand the origin of life
but um it's not a single reaction it's a
tremendously long
distance from prebiotic chemistry from
the simplest
stirrings of chemistry to a bacterial
cell with
with uh molecular machines and genes and
so on
and so you know we still need to
understand that
long continuum with the same kind of
reasoning
that answers the chicken and the egg
question which is to say
how does one thing lead to another how
does it change how does it evolve over
time
i actually do think we have a credible
theory already
for the life maybe theory's too strong a
word for it
i think we have a lot of a lot of
hypotheses
uh i personally think that i can
probably get my head around
how things happened but what's lacking
is strong evidence for that and so it
doesn't become a scientific theory until
we
were able to say okay this step leads to
this step and we do the entire continuum
and we prove in the lab that each step
can work and then we have a credible
theory it doesn't prove that's how life
started
but it proves we can understand how a
sterile planet can give rise to
life so i think we can answer it already
in principle if not in practice
brilliant well thanks for that nick i
mean
dan what what are your thoughts can we
can we put together credible theory
uh yes we can um it's actually not the
philosopher's job to come up with these
theories
it's a it's a job for science and right
now there's a
there's an embarrassment of riches we
have more hypotheses out there than
than than we can even test at the moment
um and as nick said
from pre-biotic chemistry to
actual reproducing simple organisms
that that's a long stretch and
every every year every month
uh pieces of how it must have gone
or might have gone uh get clearer
uh what fascinates me about it
is that if you
i as an outsider as a philosopher
reading this work
i'm delighted to see
the extent to which
people not only admit
that life is machinery they use the word
machine
they describe ribosomes and and
mitochondria
as these wonderful machines they are
as i like to say we're robots made of
robots made of robots
robots and and
the reason it's been only recently i
think
that people have been able to
make real progress on these questions is
thanks to 20th century pioneers
we now have disciplined ways
of thinking about machines with billions
or trillions of parks
and descartes couldn't think of that
thought
aristotle couldn't think that thought
now
we are unleashed to imagine
a machine with a trillion working parts
and we can do it with some
with some discipline and that's where
that's where the action is sarah i mean
what are what are your thoughts on this
on this question i think most of the
issue is that we've been really focused
on
trying to understand what the definition
of life is that we're trying to solve
and i think that's a big part of the
problem that really hasn't entered into
considerations about these very
hypotheses they're not really they're
making statements about some aspects of
life but not
encompassing in the way that nick was
saying of like the origin and all of
evolution of life
um and so when i think about this
problem i think at what level
of description is a theory of life going
to be
um and what level of explanation are we
asking for
um and just to give sort of analogy
because um my background's in physics i
think of sort of current frameworks for
thinking about life sort of like
at the epic cycle phase of development
of understanding gravity so like several
thousand years ago
you know we have predictive and
descriptive models that were adequate
for the time and adequate for the
observations that we could take
and it took you know 1500 years for
physics to emerge as a discipline and
and galileo and newton to actually unify
terrestrial and celestial motion
and realize that there was an underlying
explanation that we call gravity for
those motions
and then einstein to actually realize
that the properties of gravity
um were derived from the curvature of
space-time
and um you know this from this very
different phenomena about the physics of
light right so
um so i'm using this as an analogy for
what we need to do
in talking about life because i think
the magnitude of the problem is actually
much deeper
in terms of our descriptions of the
physical world and how we understand it
than people give it credit for
and most of the time when i hear
discussions about origins of life
they're kind of in the epicycle phase
and we're not asking these deeper
questions about why is it our current
physics
theories can't account for all of the
richness that we see in life and they're
not explanatory of what we see in life
it doesn't mean those theories are wrong
they're right in the domains they were
developed for
but it might be that we need new
physical principles and new laws of
nature to actually describe
life and just as an example in reference
to the chicken and egg problem
there is a chicken and egg problem in
physics which is that in the time of
newton when he came up with
the idea of physics that that most of
physics is built on now
he built physics thinking that there
were dynamical laws
that existed outside of the universe and
outside of time and they were immutable
and that requires an initial state for
the universe that you have to specify
or any dynamical system you want to
study in biology that gets really
tangled
because we have this kind of effect in
living systems where it looks like
the rules depend on the systems that
exist they depend on the actual
things that are there so um it's a very
different kind of system and in some way
you could think about the law depending
on the state
um and so they're actually not separable
um and this is sort of one of the issues
the chicken and the egg
in physics we have laws and states in
biology they're actually the same thing
i specify my dynamics as a a living
system i can
move about and i have you know causal
efficacy and things so
um so i think really the the underlying
issue is
what kind of explanatory theory do we
need to account for life and how much of
our current understanding
is going to be reinvented by coming up
with this theory and really thinking
about life as a real phenomena that
exists in the universe and needs
explanation
awesome okay well that's
a really great overview to this problem
the three of you given me
and so i want to move on to the sort of
first theme of this debate and i kind of
really
a little bit back i guess um and you
know before we
we get into this sort of details of how
life originated
it would you know i think we would do
really well to clarify you know what is
what actually is this thing called life
that we're trying to investigate in the
first place
you know what makes it so interesting so
you know
yeah nick what are your thoughts on that
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you